so the Mandalorian is back and as always
we're bringing you a big breakdown from
a galaxy far far away in this video
we're going to be going over season 3
episode 2 and recapping all the Easter
eggs plot details and all the things you
missed I just want to get straight into
it but please hit the Thumbs Up Button
if you enjoy the video and don't forget
to subscribe for breakdowns like this
every day we've also just launched
Eclipse Channel which is full of heavy
spoilers highlights so make sure you
head over there right after this anyway
enough of me pushing my what you
want to hear us go over is episode 2 and
we begin on Tatooine during the bunta
Eve celebrations we start off seeing
fireworks being shot into the air and
celebrations like this of course happen
at the end of Return of the Jedi I'm
pretty sure that the fireworks are
outlawed under the Imperial rule but the
Huts did control this sector until Boba
took over now in the opening we catch
two v-35 land Speeders racing through
the streets and you might recognize this
vehicle is summing a popped up during a
new hope the boonde eve pod race is
summing up we also witnessed during the
Phantom Menace with it being an annual
event that took place during the
celebrations Boon to Eve came about when
Boon to holistic
ascended to godhead definitely pronounce
that right and that was the first to do
so so since then the anniversary of it's
been marked by this occasion also I love
how we can catch this guy doing donuts
in the opening nice anyway we are of
course visiting Tatooine since Boba Fett
took over I think it very much mirrors
Navarro and how that became a more upper
class area now we find ourselves
returning to Pali motto
[Music]
anyway she's running a scam with some
jowas and as we learned when we saw her
last she has a fairy fetish the rodian
that she's talking to is now also
wearing upper class clothes resembling
grief cargo's Globe since he became the
magistrate High magistrate sorry High
magistrate now I think this is just put
in place to once more Hammer home how
the economy is thriving but pellis used
this opportunity to make even more money
in the hang now we can catch a BD Droid
once more along with some petroids who
also debuted in The Phantom Menace you
can also catch a periscope Droid and R5
who becomes a big character in the entry
it turns out that Jowers have taken this
customer's engine and they're basically
stealing people's stuff and then selling
it back to them Jowers or other
creatures that I think might pop up from
time to time and we know from last week
that they were the ones who gave Mando a
piece of Mandalore he comes in riding on
a ship purring like a nozzle shrew and
we see his grow good as a Jedi flip out
the cockpit this is something that he of
course learned from Luke who was
training him in the ways of the force
reminded me a lot of when he ordered it
during attack of the Clones and it's
sort of like poetry they Rhyme now pelly
brings up Boba and then the huts with
her asking if they're back I totally
forgot that they'd left the planet in
book of Boba Fett and I'll never forgive
them for saying that the Pikes scare
them enough to leave they they ran the
planet for centuries like what the
anyway I suppose there was a power
vacuum after jebber died but either way
the planet now belongs to Boba anyway
ig11 needs a memory circuit but with
jaws being unable to provide one he ends
up going to Mandalore with R5 Instead
This is to do some traded for spelunking
spelunking pretty useful lunking
I thought it might be a reference to
Batman Begins what's your interest in it
Mr Wing
I want to borrow it
for uh spelunking
spelunking R5 is still completely burst
up and in case you missed our last video
then this next bit's for you so R5 was
the same draw that Uncle Owen originally
tried to purchase all the way back in a
new Hub and as he was going forward his
motivator bus stop on the back of him we
can still see the oil leaking out and
it's clear that he's had better days now
there actually was a non-cannon comic
that stayed he was a Jedi and it said
that he actually self-sabotaged so that
R2 could go with Luke yeah though we see
the Droid is scared to leave the hangar
even though Pele insists that he once
fought with the Rebellion personally I
think that's all a lie and you you could
say that when it comes to getting Mando
excited take him that is a bad motivator
anyway because it's Boon to Eve Perry
will give it to Mando for half price and
throw in a free oil bath we've seen
these before in The Saga and C-3PO took
one after Luke bought him in R2 now we
could at the night time to see the
celebration still going and it's such a
cool way to start the episode Time
titled the minds of Mandalore this sees
Mando and grogu next heading to well
well you guessed it they arrive at
Mandalore and dinjar and brings up how
the planet used to be luscious and green
this is the case too and like Tatooine
it was filled with tropical rainforests
luscious oceans and lots of rivers the
mandalorians also used to be sworn
enemies against the Jedi but then a
Mandalorian Jedi named tarvisler Rose up
and United them wielding the darksaber
he brought the people together and this
is why it's become such a precious item
and space Mano also points on his home
planet which is called Concordia at the
end of the Mandalore War this was turned
into a mining Base by insurgents which
wiped out most of the moon's forests
eventually these were abandoned though
and the moon once more started to arrive
until the next civil war The Winning
Side Exile the losers to the Moon which
is where they remained ever since it's a
bit like Australia when Brits used to
send prisoners there but over time they
became far more civilized than our
Aussie cousins
anyway Concordia build up its own
governor and became a prosperous place
until Civil War fractured the alliances
this idea of the mandalorians constantly
being at war with each other is summing
up balkatan touched upon last week but I
can very much see her and Mando bringing
everyone together they both represent
opposite sides of the Divide but if they
can work together then everyone can now
that Mando has been quote unquote
redeemed in the Living Waters I'm
thinking he could return and bring them
all together Amanda also points out
where Bo is and he gives a lesson to
grogu and that's kalavala where we
visited Boca town this foreshadows him
having to reach out to her later on
which we'll talk more about in just a
bit Amanda also has to travel through a
storm to get to the surface and we learn
that the magnetic field around the
planet has been disrupted by Fusion
bombs first mentioned in the 1977 Star
Wars comic issue 53 it's possible that
these weapons were also used during the
Battle of mindor they've completely
up the planet and we could also
catch giant green gem-like structures
now popping out the surface this is made
of the same material at the Jowers gated
in jarin and it's clear that they
visited it highlighting how the air is
safe to breathe now as they land we see
several Rocky formations and shout outs
to our editor map for pointing out that
these look similar to palpatines thrown
on hexagol the destruction of Mandalore
is also reminiscent of the glassing in
Halo and it's transformed the planet to
have this almost mirror-like surface but
something lurks in the caves and
crevices and after all five stops
responding Mando goes in to investigate
as he jumps down we can also catch the
sundari which we get a better look at
later in the episode this was the
capital of Mandalore and it was
destroyed during the night of a thousand
tiers this was playing upon the night of
broken glass which happened during the
second world war in the ghettos with the
Nazis enacting their plan against the
Jews the event completely destroyed the
sundari and most of the planet leading
to the wreck that we see it as here now
as Mana goes deeper underground he comes
across several creatures and and these
reminded me a lot of the salt vampires
from Star Trek I also got a lot of Vibes
of the morlocks from the time machine
and all in all they just add more horror
elements to this entry now similar to
the morlocks these humanoid creatures
lived underground and attacked from dark
caves known as alamites they don't stand
well against the darksaber but it's
clear that Mando still has a lot of
difficulty wielding it Bo on the other
hand doesn't because she's used the
weapon before and it's found the inner
peace that's needed to do so Mando still
feels that odds with himself due to not
having bathed in the Living Waters yet
and it's possible that next week he may
be able to wield the blade finally Ian
gragu dive off the edge and into the
lower parts of the city and this
reminded me a lot of The Descent that
happens in Water World by very much
traveling until lost and forgotten land
that was once a thriving Metropolis you
compare this to how it looked in the
Clone Wars and the city is a shadow of
its former self now shrouded in darkness
it very much juxtaposes Navarro and
Tatooine and whereas they Thrive their
this place has gone to all that's
left are creatures lurking in the
shadows and we come across several as
they drop in I really love the horror
aesthetic that this takes on and it very
much becomes similar to Joseph
Campbell's hero's journey this involved
traveling into the belly of the beast in
order to go about a major transformation
and this could end up cementing the
change that Mando has with the darksaber
next week down there we can see several
lizard-like creatures lurking in the
shadows and they carry green eyes
similar to the alamites it's possible
that the fusion bombing actually turned
their eyes like this but that might be a
reach because we do talk a lot of
nonsense to be fair anyway as he goes
further in he finds a Mandalorian helmet
when the first trailer dropped many
believe that this was tall vizlas he was
the Mandalorian Jedi who crafted the
darksaber and brought the people
together however sadly that isn't the
case it just uses bait so that Mano can
get grabbed and this happens with a
modified crab Droid these machines were
used by the Confederacy of independent
systems during the Clone Wars and they
were mainly used on soft terrain like
San and did it carries Mando off and we
get a similar shot to what happens in
Gladiator when Maximus is being escored
away the Droid carries a cage on its
stomach and inside lies a biomechanical
Droid that's modified itself similar to
General Grievous I'd say Droid it might
be a creature but very strange looking
and very scary as well ABS I do like the
design of it though and it has flashes
of massive frenzy from Transformers and
lots of little things pulling together
for this creepy aesthetic there are
yellow pipes on its body and these
reminded me a lot of the ones that we
see in Pub's base at the start of Rise
of Skywalker to me they looked a lot
like snake skin and I definitely felt
that there were flashes of the xenomorph
2. the Cyclops iron also appears like
it's just the left one which throws you
off balance a bit and adds another
dimension to the creature now grow goo
sneaks over to Mandel but he's unable to
free him and he Force flips out of there
before returning to the surface like
Ellie he's now on his own without his
dad and we see one of the crocodile
creatures Lurch out at him revealing its
wings I think that this might be a
slight redesign of the Petra saw from
the Star Wars Universe they're all so
native to Mandalore and pull from
dinosaurs like what this crocodile
creature here looks like now one of the
alamites goes to grab grogu on the
surface before he Force pushes it like
it's the like button and the bats Hoops
in and attacks as pelly mentioned
earlier R5 has the ability to Pilot the
ship nisragu has to just point the way
this is the way he says and he takes us
to Bal Katan and I legitimately thought
that she was just gonna go out there and
start shooting at him it was all like
let's get rid of him once and for all
but now upon seeing Ragu is on his own
she's shaking out of her apathy Bo says
that she wants to be left alone but
knowing how lonely this can be she heads
out to Mandalore with him at this point
we see her ship The Gauntlet which I
think is one of the coolest crafts in
Star Wars the comrak fighter has a Class
1 hyperdrive and four laser cannons with
the capabilities of both forwards and
backwards fire it cuts through this
Skyline and I loved watching The View as
it passes over the destroyed tsundere
this is very symbolic of how Bo feels at
the moment and she's a shell of her
former self just like that is she
alongingly stares at it and I love how
you can see little details on the wings
such as them vibrating as they move
through the air when designing the
concepts for the universe Ralph
Macquarie wanted to give everything
that's lived in feeling which I think is
definitely ham at home in moments like
this watching the ship land just gives
it this feeling of weight to everything
and it's such a cool moment now as bow
and grago head in we watch R5 plugging
into the ship this is a data port and
it's a similar thing to what we've seen
characters like R2 and Echo access as
they go closer in I also got Vibes of
the original Krypton design in the
Superman movies and this crystalline
surface carries both a feeling of beauty
and horror within it inside Bo
reminisces of her past and talks about
how her family used to rule it all this
is correct too as her sister was the
teen The Duchess of the planet she'd all
the Civil Wars at a direct Mandalore she
wanted to bring peace to the planet and
she was a pacifist many of the
mandalorians rejected this ideology
though and eventually she and the planet
were pulled into the Clone Wars Obi-Wan
was besotted by her and at one point he
even admitted that he would have left
the Jedi Order if she'd asked him to Bo
says that she's fought alongside the
Jedi and this is something that we also
saw throughout the show she and Ahsoka
became allies after they start off on
the wrong foot and I'd love to see the
pair reunited in the series down here
she then encounters the alamites and she
bursts out her double pistols wire and
also her Shield known as a personal
combat Shield they're activated from the
Mandalorian van braces and are capable
of blocking Blaster bolts and also
lightsabers she says that the elements
used to live in the wastelands and that
if they survive then other things may
have too this very much foreshadows
reveal at the end which will also talk
about in just a bit now she heads for
further in we find the creature in its
Lair we don't actually find out what
it's up to but it seems to be draining
blood from him and this could be being
used to keep the tissue alive inside it
it is part machine and yeah that's just
a theory I had when watching this play
out to you
well it's clearly been draining several
mandalorians due to the helmets and it
might work as a sort of vampire parasite
Bo then launches her attack and though
she can't use the force she pulls the
darksaber to her hand she then stabs the
creature and I got a lot of Vibes of
John carp in this thing when the head
came off and started to crawl away no
matter what part of that you killed it
was always able to keep going if another
part survived and ends up jumping into
the crap Droid this kind of plays out
like a quick Time Event and buy a small
Fireball makes Manos and pork soup I
think this might mean porks and it my
bad look now she says grogu is a good
Navigator and it's possible that all
Jedi carry this innate ability due to
them being one with the force Luke
managed to find dagger bar and navigate
his
instinctively and grogu may have done
the same thing I love how gragu reaches
out for the pork soup desperate for some
and after its drank they end up going to
the mines Bo very much sees everything
like this as upon his myth but come the
end I think she will start to believe
she encounters a literal mythosaur and
yeah bit on the nose but the myths she
saw might be coming true now they head
out to the mines themselves and these
Echo the minds of Moria from Lord of the
Rings she states that the Civil Wars
made the mandalorians weak and we know
from the Clone Wars that she also
started dislike the pacifists both of
these sides very much led to the
downfall of Mandalore and I think that
the union is the only way forward button
also brings up her father Adonai who was
first mentioned in the Builder
Millennium Falcon book it was a very
obscure reference that but he was killed
during the Great Clan Wars which is when
he was then succeeded by sateen though
and her story actually remind me a lot
of the myth of Anastasia who apparently
managed to escape the exit execution of
the Russian Tsar it was thought for some
time that she got away and I don't know
if I'm reaching out with that but I saw
a lot of similarities in their story
finally they reached the chambers of the
Living Water and Beau brings up how it
ties in with the history of Mandalore
Mandalore the great apparently tamed the
first mythosaur here and the Beast then
became their Signet these stories are
documented in ancient songs you can find
on the Star Wars Wiki and they're all
kind of tying it together so that it's
all connected
now in another Lord of the Rings
reference we watch as Mando has pulled
into the water similar how Frodo was by
The Watcher this is the second time
Bowers had to save him from some water
she Dives in after him which is when she
comes eye to eye with the mythical it's
such a cool way to end the episode with
it appearing almost like a Kaiju I love
how there's this repeated theme of eyes
throughout the episode up until now they
were thought to be extinct but that was
a lie similar to The Curse the
rumors of their deaths have been greatly
exaggerated and it leads to number of
possible routes that they could take
things in the future now personally I
think that the mythosaurs likely lay
dormant on the planet and thus the
mandalorians start to believe that
they'd been wiped out they had been
hunted to an extreme and it makes sense
that they then Retreat however the
bombings could have awakened them and
Upon returning they might have seen that
the mandalorians had either been killed
or ousted I very much review the scene
as an Awakening and it could highlight
what will be happening with the
Mandalorian next the book of Boba Fett
feature the titular character taming a
rank call and he ended up riding this
into battle I think a similar thing
could happen in the series with Mano
taming one which is set up by the line
in which Bell discusses Mandalore the
great if he Masters that in the
darksaber then he would be a fearsome
symbol riding into battle that would
Echo some of the great Mandalorian
Legends him sitting on top of a
mythosaur wielding the blade would be
such a cool sight and I definitely hope
that's the way things go in the future
now as for my thoughts on the episode I
like this better than last week and even
though I thought that was good as well I
think this one just had more styling
substance you know I love my Horrors and
seeing this seben of the show was such a
cool direction to take things the
creature designer points was so good and
it added an extra Dimension to
everything always good watching balkatan
busting people up too and though I
initially thought that they'd be enemies
I think having them working together is
much much better really strong episode
and this is pretty much the episode two
that I think season two should have had
both were one stories but this one had
substance to it as well with us learning
about the law and so they're just being
that big spider thing so yeah that's my
thoughts really enjoyed it and you know
what people keep saying I'm sure yeah
but you go back to my episode 2 season 2
breakdown yeah you'll see I said I
didn't think that was very good this was
the right way to do it didn't feel like
filler and all in all I really enjoyed
the episode obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts so comment below and let
me know and just to let you know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away the rocky 4K box set to
three subscribers on the 15th of March
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe and notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode you pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our Brighton of The Last of Us which
will be linked on screen right now lots
of things to talk about lots of things
to go over there so definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for singing through the video having
Paul I see you next time take care peace